uh first of all i'd like to thank the
organizer for giving me the opportunity
to talk here
so they
this is the third quantum subject to you
and somehow the idea is of course i like
to somehow they
explain the relation between mathematics
of tensors and the physics of
entanglement and actually we are talking
exactly the same things
and compared to the two previous talks
the my talk
is very basic uh partially because
originally somehow they have invited me
i thought i couldn't be the only
physicist here so
i try to be
very somehow they take this opportunity
to somehow they connect what we are
doing with physics to the expert
and as a matter of fact as you can see
soon
i've been working on the some geometric
aspect of the entanglement
and i was contacted several times by you
know the expert in algebraic geometry or
invariant theory but i never had the
chance to somehow meet the you know the
meeting person so i like to take this
opportunity to somehow convey
and connect the
the ideas here so the first subject is a
pretty much similar subject
to the previous two talks but
i put more emphasis on the geometric
aspect
and you might expect i'm going to teach
you quantum mechanics but you are going
to be wrong because i come here to learn
quantum mechanics from you because i'm
going to say quantum mechanics or at
least the classification of the
entanglement is nothing but algebraic
geometry which you know much better than
me so i learn from you about quantum
mechanics in part one sorry and of the
part two i briefly mentioned the
uh the complexity aspect so the in the
first day we saw a lot of property like
people talk about the tensor lung border
lungs and you can find this quantity is
actually important physically in the
sense that they characterize the
uh resource quality if you try to use
such
for example the the tenth alarm is one
of the measures called the amount of
entanglement and this character is how
useful it is if you use for quantum
computation so this is what i briefly uh
talk about the second part
so the
first things is the
about the
essential connections algebraic geometry
and as i mentioned
please feel free to interrupt me if you
have any questions because this is my
purpose to connect
the idea to you so the i start with the
stochastic lcc of which you have already
twice today so
um
essentially the same things and if i
little bit to the complement to the idea
so we like to define equivalence class
of the entanglement or the algorithm has
pure states
okay
and the idea is if somehow they are
connected by the invasive operation
which are given by the special linear
group
acting locally in this way then you
could expect they have
such a similar resource called if you if
you use such steps for quantum
information processing you know there
are a lot of applications which i don't
explain but they like the whole
teleportation secret sharing or quantum
computation so the entitlement is
resource so what we like to do is
basically characterize and first step is
define equivalence class the strict the
definition could be the so-called llcc
because you care about the probability
of success in
information processing um but they often
somehow you know as somehow they start
you might think well i don't care about
the probability because they are related
by the uh invertebrates so if you
succeed this one there's some chance you
succeed using the cypress okay
so this is how we define the
equivalence on the srcc
and usually somehow this is talks about
the hilbert space in this home
but the what we actually mean is the
lace in kilowatt space the reason is
somehow the overall complex factor
doesn't affect
the any probability in physics so that
what we are really talking
is the uh essential layer phrase
differently we are talking about the
complex projective
subspace so the basic dimension is the
you know this total dimension minus one
and then um
probably if someone has to play the
question up to this moment the
srcc classification is nothing but the
classification of the orbits and this is
the
local the special linear group actions
in the complex projective
subspace compress the projected space
um
at this moment probably you know better
than me what
we can do but let me start with the
bar fighter case meaning that
what if we just apply this
strategy in the matrix so for the case
of the matrix we have the two indices by
i sub 1 and i sub 2
and if you can apply these parties what
usually called alison both
and somehow the excel cc actions this
means that essentially if you have this
reaction group action z
it corresponds to the matrix
transformation and one is acting from
left because it acts on the first index
and m2 is acting from the right because
it has done here and this is nothing but
the singular value of
the compositions
so that is why if you can apply this to
the
excel cc namely these the m1 m2s are
invertible this special linear operator
then you realize what is in variance so
the invariant is simply length of this
matrix this is only thing you cannot
change so the
equivalence class characteristic just
rank here and usually
faces some highlight on the right
diagram but for convenience i don't know
the more geometric fixture on the left
so this is the picture probably you
prefer so the whole space the whole
space is given by the complex project
space of dimension k squared minus 1 in
this case
and the
we have the lot of closure as i
elaborate soon and they are
characterized by the lung okay so the
whole space is the rank uh equal or less
than k and the next is of course rank is
the equal or less than k minus symbol
and
the the bottom one is just we call this
product what you may call the simple
tensor appearance
here
so the first thing is we characterize
equivalent classes in this case k
classes
and then
in physics we are interested in the
relations
and we can show that this rank
is not increasing under llcc meaning
that you cannot create the higher state
from the lower states because
entanglement is just consumed
so there is only some has no invertible
possibilities so you can somehow degrade
or consume entanglement from the upper
level to the lower but not as realized
place differently if you apply
no invertible g-action here you can only
somehow reduce number of the lung which
you can easily see for the case of the
matrices
and if we take the
geometric understanding then this is
nothing but the whole species as i said
are complex project space and the bottom
one the middle one corresponds to the
long one
tensor is the so-called cellular variety
we call the product states or separable
set meaning that they are not correlated
at all and there are a lot of some high
team intermediate to the
uh closures and they are essentially the
second variety
the definition of maximally entangled is
just
in the talk of this morning that you
can trace and get the identity in all
possible
okay i recommend that actually the
um
who's the case of the bipartisan
entanglement see
um
well as you notice the
um there are
you know you could just consider how you
could define machinery entangled and
what we did is we somehow in this case
we have only nine types although of
course we have a lot of state inside of
the class
and but we have only nine kinds and you
called this the
highest weight class as a maximally
entangled state i mean it comes with lot
of some states because somehow it goes
everywhere but the other states cannot
come here so the usually somehow the
definition of dimensionally end time
state comes from the operational
possibility
and that's because it's the highest of
the nine in this but there are nine for
every key
so i don't know
i don't understand
so the
the top orbit closure is the maximum
one
yeah so my definition is different from
zero definition
in particular the reason some people
might define the
maximally anton set from the spectrum of
the local dense operator
total one is if you somehow consider the
state inside of this one
so the
you know as far as somehow lung is
through florence they all stays included
here
but if you consider this somehow this
equal weighted state
is most
powerful in the sense that this state
has kind of the best probably if you
really care about the
probability inside the class okay some
state may have the better performance
although all are somehow connected
by the good fraction
and that is why somehow somehow old
songs are equally weighted phrase
differences local density operators
identity
it is preferred the
representative state in the class so
this is you know so his definition is a
little bit lower than the i'm using here
does this have to do with this business
of this critical uh states that was um
no
how do you distinguish which one of
these has the best performance within
the class so the in our case you have to
think the so the slo cc is the
consequent characterization so if you
care about the probability you have to
introduce different equivalence class
so usually people might consider local
unitary equivalence and you have to
compare somehow the phasor somehow this
direction you know sometimes in one
direction is probability one but the
other maybe some has worked only
probabilistically and you can really
somehow compute which ones
you know has the best somehow the
performance
but here somehow
what i'm saying is we are doing this
under the slcc we are doing the course
grant classification and we have only
nine
kinds of entanglement here
so just remember so you know it's
because you take you don't take unitary
transformation so so therefore maximum
tangled in gilad is the same as here if
you just identify as one orbital
yes sure
i mean it's included here yes
can you say i'm sorry to ask this
are you saying nine like the number nine
or you're saying something else because
i don't i see k
different states you guys say nine yeah
oh sorry
no it's there here oh sorry about i
don't know why i say
no so it's the k so the whole case with
it
k times k we have the k classes okay
everything is clear
okay and obviously this and so the whole
case of the bipartite or the matrix you
know we can so that our goal is we like
to do the similar process of the tensors
um
but the question is how we can draw
these
closures and probably you know but one
idea you can look
is the
one you know of course here already
somehow i somehow described answers but
one
ideas look
they of course we can always define the
separate state as a few attempts
and there is famous duality in complex
uh projective space never is the duality
between the
the space of the
the dimension
of the
the secular variety and its
dual variety which has a co-dimension
one in this case
so this duality here and the
largest the sub variety and which is
characterized by determinants because
this set is nothing but the rank
is equal to or less than k minus one
okay so this is
and all somehow
intermediate closures are characterized
as the sum has the singularity of the
dual varieties so the my approach
is essentially we are going to define
this first duality and try to look at
the singularities to somehow do the same
you know pictures for the case of the
tensors
is everything clear
okay
so uh i think we already saw so i don't
repeat
so the first question is how about the
two by two by two case what we call
three cubic case
and as david pointed out the
when i you know
the people in quantum information got
interested in the
uh multiplied entanglement basically
what surprised us first was the
if you look at the multipatter case see
there is
well there are
several ways to be the maximally
entangled in some sense okay um
of course i mean
if you look at the mathematical
literature of course uh you know for
example the
you know the same remarks can be found
in this textbook by the girlfriend
kaplan of trevinsky about the
discriminant resultant and the
multidimensional
determinant and if you look at the last
page they just
they
kind of write down the result hold the
case of the two by two by two
uh without much explanation
but the somehow the
thesis found the meaning of this you
know characterization
uh this is what we like to do in more
and the
the story of the today
so the now i like to define
duality and usually this is a slide i
kill all attention
of pieces
but
probably i don't have to even explain to
you here
so the idea is somehow we like to define
the similar correspondence between the
segue variety and the determinant
and the this is how
girlfriend and his collaborators define
the duality
okay so we consider the
set x and who our case we are going to
define x to be the
second
variety namely the set of the completed
several states and the dual variety is
defined in such manner that this state
is included in the dual variety uh if
there exists a point on the secular
variety here somehow this tangent
uh the hyperplane somehow tangent uh to
this variety x
um well usually somehow i try to explain
what is the meaning of the hyperplane
this is kind of the set of the original
state to the
side in this picture but probably you
are much familiar with this definition
so the weakness of the muscle in your
home this way and the condition i just
phrased here with the dual variety is
nothing but the the set of the
uh this is the linear home and the first
derivative for every
x
should have at least one nonzero
solution okay to have the tangent point
and the condition for this z
uh this existence is nothing but the uh
condition of the dual variety and
if
if this is co-dimension one you know and
this happens only when we have specific
somehow forma roughly speaking somehow
the old somehow the subsystem should be
small and originally smaller
than the the rest of the
states then somehow we can define the
one somehow the hypersurface
here and this is the definition of the
hyper determinant in general
any question in this slide is this okay
okay good
okay so
and there are a lot of things known
about hyperedition so they hold the two
by two case the it's just standard
italian and they carry found the
in nineteenth centuries this is the
third hyper determinant of degree 4
and as i briefly mentioned this quantity
is
good to characterize entanglement in the
sense that this absolute value somehow
characterize the
amount of genuine
much patent component in entanglement on
the other hand this anecdote hyper
determinant is very complicated object
in the sense that the degrees
is known to be growing up very fastly so
even 40 degree 24 and you know blah blah
blah and if i know correctly there are
still active
activities on this to characterize this
hyper determinant in terms of you know
decompose monomial and how many times
you have
and but this
this is what we like to do essentially
we like to somehow define hyper
determinants and conceptually we like to
look at the singularity of this hyper
design because these are some houses and
it gives us different entangled states
so this is
my interpretation of the known results
but you might somehow figure out the
better let's
look at more carefully so the whole
space is the dimension seven because we
have three cubits nearly two by two by
two
and the there is first somehow close
variety is given by the dual variety and
definition is hyperdeterminant itself
and the outside of this state out sorry
outside of this dual variety
is the most generic of it
of dimension seven and you can find one
example and this is so called the dhc
state
so this is the gst class is
mathematically defined as the whole
state
uh
you know and the substrate the dual
variety here
and next
is the
well you know as i said first of all we
consider the segue
variety in the middle and we took the
duality and they are somehow
intermediate
varieties are three ways because
naturally you realize that
there are some has three ways to
consider the secular embedding of the
ct1 times cp3 okay because we have the
three cubits so you can somehow combine
two in three ways
so the
w class
is essentially outside of these the
combinations of the
three possible this
cellular embedding
and this is somehow the by definition
you can see that this class
is 35 tight and tungsten
but it's separate from ghz in the sense
that the
the dimensions of it is
the
the six
and the you know typically we took the
this w state as one representative
in this region
and as i mentioned there some has three
dimensions for singular varieties by ct1
and cp3 here
and the in the union the the
dimension 3 of these
secular variety in terms of city one
time city one times sigma is the
smallest cross variety in this city
and
in principles we got the old
characterization of the orbit you know
in this way
and the
uh
conceptually some had also that i
characterized that the these somehow
you know the
second
varieties can be said as the
singularity of the dual variety in the
sense that the if somehow the hyperplane
is tangent to the two point at the
completely
separate set namely on the x then it
becomes kind of the node
kind of the singularity and this is the
characterization
of this three cp1 times cp3 and when
somehow the tangent hyperplane somehow
touches this way namely the second
derivative is also zero then it becomes
as a cusp and the actual cp1 times cp1
times cpu
is nothing but the cusp singularity of
the dual variety
so the
i kind of guess you may have the better
tools to somehow do things
these things but that's the problem i
somehow they started looking at in the
past and i have few more somehow the
example along with this line is there
any question up to here
can you be a little more specific about
what cuspid node means exactly okay so
the
whole this is singularity so the if we
have the more than one solution okay
well x is some high dimensionals i don't
know how to say it in fact x is a high
dimensional space right it's not like a
curve
right so what is so the the dual variety
is these tangent typer planes that is
the hyperplane intersect x is singular
okay and there's two ways you can have
singularity that's not a a1 singularity
either you have a2 or greater
singularity which is cusp
or you're or it's singular at more than
one point that's node
the hyperplane section h intersect x
is singular
so it could either have
one
generically it'll be a single a1
singularity yes okay after that there's
two choices it could either be an a2 or
bigger singularity
so so we're just called cusp so the size
that i'm asking here is you always see
figure what
in this example do you ever see bigger
than a2
you you of course will see bigger than
a2
in general
what's the next worst thing that could
happen
yeah i mean if you if you're on the
segway it's going to be much worse than
a2 because it's okay yeah but
like sanji was close
okay um
so
so this is what i got hold a little bit
bigger case for example we consider two
by two by four case
and then we see the same structure in in
the middle part so the this part is same
as the three cubic case but now this sum
has the
the
you know the dimension is full so we
have more orbits
and the idea is we can somehow consider
there's some graduality between the
uh the varieties
and actually the
dual variety of the this the total space
name the the the sub variety of code
dimension one is the dual to the b3 in
this case uh bisector between
i think this is b3 is cp3 times cp3 and
the dual
is somehow the
closed variety of code dimension one and
similarly the
dual variety of the complete separate
state is given to this intermediate
the orbits but the
in a nutshell we can somehow they
characterize every orbit in terms of the
the algebraic varieties
um in this case i think we have nine
sorry so that probably this is the
reason you know in my mind always knife
is in my mind so we have the nine
different enzyme classes here
and
the
you know as already somehow they
mentioned in this case we still have the
finite classes
but the it is known that if you consider
more parties like the fourth qubit or
the in general we have infinitely
remaining causes in the sense that we
have we may have the finitely many uh
closed varieties but in between
we have infinite many orbits in general
and if you like to somehow they classify
you know the algebra algebraically so
these nine classes uh in
in principle you can use a lot of
somehow the good invariant and we call
entanglement measures
um for example generic class of course
we can just check the
uh the essential local lungs so this is
a little bit similar to as david said
the
uh for given total state you can easily
calculate the
reduced operator for the ice part by
tracing out the rest and you can easily
calculate the lungs and if somehow along
with 2 and 2 and 4 full in the whole
the subspace then you can easily say
this is somehow the generic of it
and if you get a two and two and three
as we saw you have the two possibilities
and this is essentially somehow
distinguished by the corresponding
detainer so for this case we have the
determinant of the two by two by three
home
and when you get the the slope the set
of the local lungs by two and two and
two
then
essentially this is what we saw they you
can use the hypodermia on this
distinguished ghd and double glass and
if you have the much smaller than they
are somehow not the genuinely prepared
end tank so if you have
you know these three possibilities
essentially uh by
separable in the sense that the only
somehow two parties are in tank and if
you have the
old one it corresponds completely
several states
um
and usually somehow the phases somehow
the
loser diagram something like that so the
whole three key we get we have only
three layers
so the surprising fact is although
somehow if you draw this diagram like
with this onion shape
ghz state is generic on the
most outer but this doesn't
guarantee actually we can convert ghz
state into the w state so if you try to
do that actually the successful provider
is punishing
so the only you can do
is the actually you can transform g8z
into the lower classes and similar
happen to the w so the difference
compared to the bipartite case is the
the hierarchy of the multiplied
entanglement is not totally ordered in
general if you consider the embodiment
transformations or phrase differently in
order to characterize much but
entanglement you need several measures
okay
for the case of the bipartite case you
can only look at the rank and somehow
determine the conversion but here the of
course the dimension is one thing but
the whole example as i somehow come to
later tenth lung
is also the one of the entanglement
measure in the sense that the tensile
lung is also decreasing that is that you
cannot go to gst to w you cannot
increase number of times here okay so
there are a lot of constraint and that
is why in data phases usually prefer to
this diagram and for the case of the two
by two by four this is the whole fixture
so we have unique class this is generic
ob and we can safely say this is much
more intense because you know from this
state you can go everywhere
but in general we don't have the unique
class in much better entanglement can
you go is it with certainty
from here to the bottom
like can you go from the top to any one
below with 100 success uh i doubt it
usually not
yes
you can easily see so this state is
nothing but somehow the two epr there
and the equation is phaser we can create
orbital state from this state and
generally know
okay so the as i briefly mentioned the
um
we could somehow continue this process
so therefore the case of the whole bit
uh this is a little bit complicated but
i think it's known as the strategies
method to construct
the detanglement of the two by two by
two by two using the smaller format of
the determinant you know using this way
and as briefly we somehow saw how to be
case we have infinitely many
slcc ob
but the generic class is always
characterized by the non-zero
hypothetical okay and naturally we have
four parameters
and the here and as far as this the
uh
fundamental determinant is not zero then
you could say this is generic whole
entanglement
and the one notice is in general g8z
noaa ws are
generic type entanglement so
they are a little bit limited although
they are very famous and easily write
down but
the zoo of the tongue is a little bit
interrogated
and the
i think that i'm a little bit behind my
schedule but they briefly mention
one open question so the for now the
when somehow the two speaker talked we
are
usually talking or they are talking
about so-called single copy
classification meaning that you have a
state just one copy and you're asking
what you can do
and in the context of the you know
quantum information also we are
interested in the asymptotic case in the
sense that we have uh infinitely many
identical copies and you could ask
phaser somehow you know
uh you know you can somehow do this
certain somehow transformation and for
the case of the bipartisan case the the
question is the suppose the psi prime is
given by this no matching oriented state
but you have the m copies and the
question is how much you can get the
marginalized state equally balanced
and the question is how many copy n
copies you can get
and it is known that the
we can make this transformation
reversible
uh
when somehow this n is given by m times
entropy of the reduced operator here
and the this is very important result in
quantum information
but the two minority we don't have any
geometric understanding what's going on
here so naturally we have the m copy so
we have
you know we could imagine this is kind
of the geometry on the symmetric
subspace and
you know we could think we could use a
lot of embedding like beyond embedding
but the difficulties usually i don't see
the entropy function algebraic geometry
maybe i'm wrong but that is why somehow
this
it's known in the context of the
information theory
but the if we consider sympathetic
settings i don't have any somehow
geometric understanding
and the furthermore in principle we like
to do
same characterization
for much further settings because this
characterization tells us if you
consider a sympathetic
situation
essentially there is only one kind of
zentangle you can count the amount of
enzymes by counting as the number of etl
states
but the question is whether we can do
same things in multi-pattern setting
so we like to somehow we compare the
arbitrary state by decomposing into the
representative state
but it is not known whether we can do
such conversion in a reversible sense
um so the people somehow called this is
this set possible kind of the unit of
the multipattered entrance set as a
minimally reversible enzyme generating
set the embryx in the sense that this
transformation can be done in a
reversible sense
i think this mathematical
difficulty is the aeros is a little bit
more complicated
than
slcc uh because we have to care about
the successful probability okay
certainly analysis includes local injury
operations but we can do more than that
so the i think that's one little bit
difficulties but if you have any idea
to see much about that settings
that speak still open question in your
community
so this is the first part of my talk any
questions so far yeah i mean how to say
i suppose i relax that niche about sllcc
because somehow the
well well in in
in basket case it is trivial but because
for each copy you can transform to the
imaginary and tangled state with same
rank right not this question
this question
okay so this of course the first
question is if we consider the m copies
then it corresponds to the we have
infinitely
many it right so in principle if we
somehow pick up with the all represented
in representative states it's doable
but even we don't have characterization
of every character you know the orbits
in my knowledge but no of course we have
this
you know the condition of the
uh symmetry namely we have identical m
copies so this should reduce the number
of possible orbits but i'm not sure
whether somehow still we can get the
final remaining many orbits
one more time so if i show that if i
convinced you that you can't do this
with slocc with finitely many generators
would you then also know that you can't
do it with locc with finitely many
generators
uh this is another question see if you
are you know address in the slocc this
is different question um but as i said
if you somehow try to you know connect
by slcc then i think only answers you
like to pick up with what's the possible
somehow the orbit we can get by constant
m copies
and the only question is whether this is
finite or infinite which i don't know
isn't it
originally we want this to be the
reverse
so we don't want so the of course the
ghz is more expensive unit okay
so the you know because if you have a
lot of bare state you can create a ghd
state but there is and now how long
uh
i mean i'm trying just to understand the
question how long how many cubits what's
the limit
like here you you add three qubits and
two cubits
what about it's from four qubits how do
we know oh suppose this is three cubic
states oh okay let's say that's fine yes
yes someone said oh no i didn't write
down the product state because this is
free resource okay
so just let you know that there are some
open questions in this context and in
remaining time i
going to briefly mention the second part
namely the complexity
and
the
as you already
sensed somehow
you know the quantum computation usually
we have the
similar diagram of the boolean network
but instead the we prepare the state and
we are after a gate operation and
usually they these gate actions are
chosen from the su-2 acting on the only
one cubit or su4 acting with the two
lines here
and naturally you can see that if you
apply su 2 it doesn't change the
entanglement of this locator so the
amount of the entanglement is modified
whenever you apply to be gate or c4
and if you consider the quantum
computation on the quantum circuit
namely starting from product set you
generate entanglement and in some moment
you like to get the output state and you
are going to measure and read out some
certainty some has answers
so the complexity
of the
quantum computation can be phrased as a
complexity of the state you generated
here namely somehow compressed of the
quantum computation is uh reflected in
the complex of the entanglement so if
you somehow characterize the
complexity of the entanglement this is
this has the implication to the quantum
computation
or limitation limitation of the quantum
computation
and the
just therefore illustration the
in principle we have a lot of
possibilities in this subject diagram
but in the past people looking at the
very simple
toolkit we get
called the control z gate
uh given by the this form meaning that
you somehow pick up the two cubits and
you provide only minus sign only when
you have the one at the both registers
otherwise it's just
you know the standard things so this is
similar to the likewise x or any logical
operation but you know in quantum case
of course we can have the minus sign
here and this is the value of the
unitary operation here
and then then somehow this
essentially the
if you have the control phase gate they
all gets a commuting because this is in
the
z basis so the uh it means that whenever
you apply a lot of the control phase
here you don't have to be worried about
orders because they are commuting so
that's the big simplification of this
the example
and that is why
we don't line this line anymore but we
just dimension the connection which
cubits are connected by the you know the
control phase gate so this diagram only
somehow this you know the
express which cubits are connected so in
this example we have two lines or two to
it and they are connected by season
and this represents nothing but the bell
type machinery and time step uh if we
somehow initialize state into the
prostate which is just this shorter
notation from the zero plus one state
you know you can just easily calculate
you know starting from the plus and the
prostate and if you apply this to the
gate then in the end you get the
essential distance and if you have the
three qubit and act this on the
neighbors then you get to the gst state
and you can do a lot of things and for
example if you have this chain of the
under acting on the neighbors uh it
somehow has the
tense of this home but i have a little
bit subscript which specifies the basis
but you can essentially see this is you
know this kind of the long tensor and
this is a little bit different from ghz
because you can see the tensile language
bigger than this this device and it is
called cluster state and you can ask
compressively this end-tone state and
you can ask phrasal somehow we can do
quantum computation using such
uh
zen tongue state
and this long story but we define graph
state in this manner namely some has a
given graph you somehow according to
this pattern the edges you apply control
phase gate
and there are a lot of varieties and
this covers a lot of important classes
like the ghd set is generally
corresponding to the distributive graph
and if you consider this the seven qubit
things it's it has some uh intrinsic
error correction property and this is
just two dimensional grid and it's
called the 2d cluster state
and also somehow i don't explain in
detail surprising fact is if you have
certain entangled set like 2d cluster
by doing just arrow cc is enough for you
to simulate any quantum computation
phrase differently so this is usually
people call universal resource for
quantum computation in the sense that if
you are provided to this entrance set
all you have to do is lcc as we saw in
the first part basically you are
starting to do the measurement and you
know doing a lot of the local
transformation and you can simulate any
quantum computation
okay so the
and if you have this some very dumb
resource you know obviously if you have
no end time state you cannot do the any
quantum computation so the apparent this
somehow gives you some idea about the
power of the quantum computation
so this is
lovely what i said um
the complexity of the state
uh
is somehow the representation of the
compression of the quantum computation
and we consider
this the set of the size
is universal for this measurement based
quantum computation if you can produce
the on any state because the in quantum
computation you are supposed to produce
any state so if you can you know
produce any set you call this the
initial
the set of state as a universal and
there are a little bit you few
details uh one thing is compared to the
first part here you may somehow change
the size of the particles okay
so the
usually you are starting from the big
resource and you are starting to do the
low cc and you are happy if you could
you know prepare any state of the target
in the lower case n and usually you want
this overhead to be polynomial large so
if this chapter n is at the most
polynomial in the target size then you
consider this original set is good okay
um
and essentially um this entangled
measure somehow tells you further
somehow that this given state passes
this the
test for the universality or not because
the entanglement is the monotonically
decreasing on the arrow cc so in order
to be the universal resource it should
have the
high entanglement because you know this
value is only decreasing so if this is
limited there's no chance to create the
entangled higher value
so that gives us the
necessary condition for universal
resources and one thing i like to
highlight is we call entangled width
which is related to the certain graph
invariant and one more thing the i
should point out here is we have this
schmidt measure but actually this is
nothing but the logarithmic of the
tensile lung so the tensile lung is also
the one another interesting thing but of
course this is a little bit sloppy to
check what's known so we have another
name unfortunate
entanglement width is
shortly said this is nothing but the
language if you know the graph theory
and we can somehow say that this is
uh essentially the good end-tone measure
in the sense that this is not increasing
and the first is the
if you calculate this quantity hold it
to the cluster set this diverges okay so
it's unbounded twice
i skip this right so the first theorem
is any set of the graph set food
entanglement width is bounded for the
number of cubic end
cannot be universal because there are
some state you cannot create
and the for example the one dimensional
classes this one dimension chain
is limited and it is not universal
because if you calculate the
three widths then this is just one
the interestingly if you look at the
tensile rank this one dimensional class
asset has still big uh
the tensor length but the this doesn't
somehow
allow us to eliminate this one d cluster
state so the my point is you know to
somehow characterize as a resource of
the quantum computation you need more
than one measures
or there might be measures but we don't
know what is for example if you look at
the only tensile you cannot tell whether
this is universal or not and there are a
lot of some has a similar
uh graph set which are not universal
like the ghz states usually we consider
this is highly in tanks but actually
this is nothing but three so it has a
limited complexity so it's not universal
and there are a lot of more examples
and this is somehow the
uh also the coincide with another idea
of the classical simulation of the
quantum circuit itself because somehow
in this argument i attribute the
complexity of quantum composition to the
entanglement but you could somehow just
add the quantum computation is nothing
but the contraction of the tensor in
certain orders
and this is
one might do the similar argument and
for example you can find the two
articles by the computer scientists for
example this first step
considers the quantum circuit so it's a
little bit maybe too small to read but
the quantum site of the tensor network
and they show that the tree width of
this tensor is limited you have chance
to simulate a whole circuit by classical
method
and this is somehow coincide with our
intuition that is this kind of the
universe okay and there are several
arguments along this line on the other
hand
there are several somehow known classes
for universal resources
and at least somehow they have unbounded
entanglement
and in particular for example we can say
that all regular
uh the
tilings into these are universal so not
only somehow scala test you can do
universal computation using different
geometry and as i already somehow
briefly
implement uh implies
we have also the generalization of the
ground state using the tensor network
set and for example the david gross has
important contribution in this clip
and the tensor network stays a little
bit popular in physics nowadays but they
are realized so they essentially you
know in the graph that we consider the
special
tools we get from control phase gate but
you don't have to consider this yet and
in general we somehow consider this
state they generated by the loss of
tensors
and i realized that there was
another workshop in the simon's
institute in this april
about the tensor network and simulations
and finally the audience and the
participants are completely different
from this
community and this is rather bunch of
the thesis and we see maybe our two
computer scientists but if you are
interested you can look at the videos of
this workshop but any anyhow the
on the second part the
the the
the conclusion well somehow we can
characterize the
compress of the quantum computation
using
measure of the entanglement and the not
to be universal the entanglement should
be microsoft
in the sense that it should somehow
scale you know essentially proportion to
the system size
and for certain measures like the
you know for example 10th arm
we can even say that this
characterization is good in the sense
that if this entanglement is only
logarithmic
scaling then you can say actually this
resource is not not only
not universal but also there's way for
you to somehow simulate exchange
research computation so that we can even
say this is in p
so this is a summary of my talk so in
the first part the i somehow gave the
my interpretation of the classification
of the entanglement in terms of the
algebraic geometry and the two big
questions obvious obviously the first
thing is the you know we have to
complete this program and i think
and also from the
uh physics perspective also we like to
understand the implication of the or
uh you know the
you know the also variety of the orbits
because somehow this sum has the
differences orbit characterized how
somehow the correlation can be shared in
the multipath setting and as well as it
was mentioned once the difference to the
classical correlation is in
entanglement we have non-trivial
constraint meaning that the entanglement
cannot be shared in an arbitrary sense
so this is called monogamy of
entanglement and essentially we like to
interpret this classification as a
physical constraint you know for example
somehow the fact somehow the
two-party only somehow you know if
somehow you guarantee that the
arizona book shares the etl state it
only somehow the guarantees that alice
and bob has the perfect correlation and
this is uh
this is this is exactly the basis of the
security in quantum cryptography okay
because there is no way somehow the
artists above is somehow connected to
this other person in this setting so
there are a lot of somehow the
application using such constraint and as
i briefly mentioned the asymptotic case
is largely open on the second part the
of course we like to somehow find the
necessary and sufficient condition even
for graph state to be universal which is
unknown
and
also the other complementary questions
they also we start looking at the class
classes of the tensor network which can
be still handled essentially classical
manner so that actually you know
we can somehow use in the variational
answers in the many body system for
example
thank you very much for your attention
what's a small example of a tensor
network for which
uh this question is open
oh oh the
well actually
the question is you know so actually
this state has own name so this is
extension of the graph that we call
matrix product state
so the for each sound has a tensor
basically you could imagine these
circles correspond to qubit and we
determined how they are connected
and this system is known to somehow
convenient to describe one-dimensional
intellectual system like you know the
david hogan talks about because this
naturally somehow causes information
about the
two body interactions okay and if you
have the higher dimensional state then
you might expect you need a more
complicated description for the
entanglement so this is you know you
know compared to this one-dimensional
description this has more long-range
interaction
so if you expect this system is more
you know correlated you know you
shoot some but the nice thing about this
is somehow so called the mirror
in the sense that somehow it represents
a lot of physical properties you expect
you know i don't somehow explain details
and on the other hand somehow there's a
good way to somehow keep contracting
things and
because if you write down the
tenses lively you may not be able to
calculate any quantities so the in
physics application you like to find the
tensor network which are efficiently
computable
so we have just those but we expect to
somehow expand more
yes
yeah so i think much of what you said at
the beginning was only for the pure
state yes what happens i mean do these
techniques tell you anything about the
mixed state case
uh
that's that's the thing so the you know
in the beginning i somehow said that i'm
going to learn from you in the sense
that we have the very nice
correspondence between the
geometry of pure state and the azerex
geometry but this breaks down
immediately if we consider
the mixed states
uh in principle i think there are some
ways to do that as we already see so if
you have the
ah two bit mix it essentially this
corresponds to the
uh four tens that you have you know so
the even potential of course even if you
do the same cc classification we have
infinite orbits so in principle you can
do but
it's much complicated immediately
any other questions
thank you very much